في البحر سمكةْ ...سمكةْ
تُحِبُّ الحَرَكَةْ..حركةْ
بِالبَحْرِ الهَائِجْ ..  تَمْضِى
تَجْتَنِبُ الشَّبَكَةْ
في البحر سمكةْ ...سمكةْ
تُحِبُّ الحَرَكَةْ..حركةْ
بِالبَحْرِ الهَائِجْ .. تَمْضِى
تَجْتَنِبُ الشَّبَكَةْ
في البَحْرِ مَوْجَةْ
تَتْبَعُهَا مَوْجَةْ
وَبِرَمْلِ الشَّاَطِئ
تَرْتَطِمُ هَوْجَاء
والسَّمَكَةُ تَسْبَحْ
بَيْنَ الأَمْوَاجِ
وتَقُولُ البَحْرُ
سِرُّ ابْتِهَاجِى
في البحر سمكةْ ...سمكةْ
تُحِبُّ الحَرَكَةْ.حركةْ
بِالبَحْرِ الهَائِجْ تَمْضِى
تَجْتَنِبُ الشَّبَكَةْ
مَامَا أَوْصَتْهَا
خَوْفًا عَلَيْهَا
حَتَّى تَحْمِيهَا
بِطَرِيقِ الرِّحْلَةْ
والسَّمَكَةُ تَتْبَعْ
نَصَاِئِحَ مَاَمَا
فَهِيَ الكَبِيرَةْ
طُرُقًا وسُبُلاَ
وبَابَا أيضا
بِوُّدٍ يُعْطِينَا
حُبًّا وَسَعَادَةْ
أَمْنًا وسَلاَمَةْ
في البحر سمكةْ ...سمكةْ
تُحِبُّ الحَرَكَةْ. حركةْ
بِالبَحْرِ الهَائِجْ تَمْضِى
تَجْتَنِبُ الشَّبَكَةْ